as kamala harris approaches the one-year
mark as vice president she has yet to
take any responsibility for her long
list of failures and there's a reason
for that she doesn't think anything is
her fault that was made clear in the new
york times article published last month
where insiders say the vice president
blames poor media coverage on her gender
and race but kamala isn't the only one
blaming others for her failures aoc is
doing the same thing the new york
congresswoman got coveted after
vacationing massless in florida last
weekend but instead of confronting her
hypocrisy head-on she blamed the black
the backlash on republicans saying quote
republicans are mad they can't date me
joining me now to react former governor
of alaska sarah palin governor always
great seeing you um
so i just wonder what would have
happened when you were getting such a
hard time by the media if you had
responded and said
justice aoc said hey you guys are just
all sexually frustrated you all want to
date me what would have happened
isn't that something that's pretty
creepy pretty junior high issue
it amazes me though her and other
liberals uh
socialists even their ability to deflect
from what the issues truly are and hear
her obsession with at least suggestions
of them
always gender and sex even it um
you know i truly believe that there are
enough americans who get it and
understand what her tactic is and that
is to deflect from what the real issues
are but uh yeah okay take this issue
though with her suggestion of dating and
um and you know attraction to someone
and uh blaming her failures on that uh
that that obsession with sex look how
the liberals rachel uh want to pound
that into the public's head
that uh advertising who is attracted to
who what people do in their own the
privacy of their own bedrooms um all
those things that have to do with uh
privacy and sex the liberals not the
conservatives are the ones who pound
pound pound after that and um obviously
it's a tactic so that she doesn't have
to be held accountable it sounds like
she hasn't been held accountable for
much
maybe in her entire life so she does not
have that foundation yeah of
accountability and um you know that
public service heart that is
so necessary in order to serve well and
be accountable
yeah i think you're right it is a form
of deflection it's also i think shows
some deep-seated narcissism but i'm
going to move on to kamala because she
says that all this is about that she's
the first right because she's the first
woman
vice president she's the first woman of
color vice president
but the first president barack obama had
it pretty good with the press so it
seems to me that that's not a really
good excuse and maybe i i'm sure you
agree with me being the outsider donald
trump actually made it was probably
harder he had not had a much harder time
with the press than than kamala or aoc
or certainly barack obama
oh absolutely and uh yeah president
trump did have it much harder it was
always three against one with trump it
was the democrats it was the press
obviously and it was the rhinos within
the establishment of the party and yet
look what trump could accomplish no same
answer with kamala and her most recent
issues and blaming gender as i had with
aoc man these fake feminists who bring
the woman's movement back so far
by
channeling everything right on back to
oh it's our gender dog got it people
don't like us because we're female
holy moly
rachel i know you having been raised
with just hard working that that work
ethic that groundedness that i think is
so necessary to be a good person and a
good public servant um rachel perhaps
again their foundation isn't um
what is commonplace in the american
populace where no gender really doesn't
matter it's the character of who you are
it's your work ethic
i'm really thankful that i was brought
up in a place where gender truly
has not mattered and
blame um you know criticisms on uh
me being female
shoot can you imagine if i would have
done that all these years um yeah what
they'd be saying
well you are a tr you are a trailblazer
governor you took the you took the
punches um very gracefully and uh
certainly the work ethic you got from
alaska
and from living up in those harsh
conditions proved itself over and over
with you so we thank you for coming on
you're a great example to women
appreciate it thank you so much rachel
you too
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else